[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a period epic film
called mongol the rise of genghis khan
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the premise of the movie is set in the
year 1172 the current northwestern
chinese provinces used to be called the
tangut kingdom ruled by the dynasty of
the same name there lived several
mongolian tribes led by their respective
leaders called the khans the rivalry
between the tribes and the hunger for
power within them caused several
arguments battles and deaths there are
no rules in the world of mongols and it
is in desperate need of a supreme khan
to lead and unite the people yesugai is
the khan of a small tribe in the west at
the beginning of the film he is
traveling with his men and nine-year-old
son to mujin to look for a wife for the
kid at night they stop at a friend's
tribe to take a rest temujin is busy
tending to his horse when a girl named
bort approaches him and asks him his
name temujin introduces himself and
tells her the purpose of the trip on
finding out he is looking for a bride
bort confidently claims that he should
marry her temujin's father wants to
bring home a bride from a stronger tribe
for politics but upon his son's repeated
request yesugai allows him to choose
someone from the friends tribe instead
before choosing the girl temujin is
asked to look for one with strong legs
because only a girl with strong legs can
keep her man happy temujin does as told
and chooses bort their marriage is
officiated but they can only be together
after five years before leaving temujin
promises to return soon and gives board
a necklace as a gift to remember him on
the way back to their village yesugai
and the men take a rest near an inn they
are cautious because a few yards away
sits the leader of a rival tribe with
his men suddenly the rival khan sends
his men with a bowl of milk as a sign of
peace to return the gesture yesugai also
sends back a bowl of juice yes you guys
right hand man suggests that he let the
servant drink the milk first since they
cannot trust their enemies but yesugai
doesn't want to lose the opportunity to
make peace because of suspicion he
drinks the bowl clean and so does the
other khan a while later they continue
the journey but a few minutes in yes you
guys chest starts to hurt he falls off
the horse and dies it is clear that the
opponents took advantage of his kindness
and poisoned him poor temujin goes to
his father but his followers could not
care less it is a tradition for the
people to only follow a strong leader
now that their leader is dead their main
concern is to find a new con not to
avenge the old one in the following
scene temujin and his mother attend yes
you guys funeral yesugai owned a lot of
cattle and houses which are taken over
by his right-hand man targutai temujin's
mother curses him and claims that her
son will kill him one day targutai
realizes it is true and makes it his
mission to kill temujin however they
measure his height which doesn't reach
the upper part of the wheel of a cart
according to the traditions mongols do
not kill a child which is why tamujin's
life is saved but targettai promises to
return next winter when temujin's height
will have increased when winter comes
around temujin has no place to hide he
remembers his father telling him about
god tengri who will help him in his time
of need hence he goes to the sacred
mountain to visit the holy place but on
the way he accidentally falls into a
frozen lake and almost dies he is
rescued by a boy his age named jamuka he
and his younger brother bring tamoojin
to their home and give him food temujin
is grateful to the brothers for saving
his life he offers to be jamuka's
brother by blood they mix their blood in
a bowl of milk and drink it to prove
their allegiance to each other huh mgk
and megan fox aren't crazy after all the
following morning they are confronted by
targettai and his people who are still
looking for temujin to kill him they
abduct him and take him back to the
tribe but fortunately for tamujin his
height hasn't grown much since the last
time so he has to be held captive until
he grows a kind old man feeds him every
day and helps him with his injuries a
few days later they measure his height
again but it still hasn't gone up
suddenly it starts to rain and everyone
goes inside their houses the old man
takes this opportunity to free temujin
the kid runs for as long as he can with
the wooden plane still stuck around his
neck he goes to the mountains and prays
to god tengri for help temujin then sees
a white wolf beside the monument of god
and seconds later the wooden plane is
miraculously broken the scene changes to
1186 temujin has grown up into an adult
but is still on the run from targutai
and his people after a years long search
they are able to capture him and lock
him in a similar wooden plane this time
he has grown enough to match the height
reference so the chances of his survival
are low targetai wants to see him beg
for his life but tamoojin being the
proud man he is refuses to do so as a
result targatai decides to torture him
slowly instead of killing him in an
instant the old man who helped tamoojin
years ago feeds him even now he begs
temujin to spare his life when he
returns to avenge the treatment he is
getting when it gets dark targatai comes
to temujin alone and mocks him since
everyone is busy tamujin takes the
opportunity to attack the opponent and
kills him by hitting him with the wooden
plane repeatedly after that he flees
from the village and is safe yet again
temujin is ready to take his tribe back
and become the khan but first he has to
bring his bride home he goes to his
in-laws tribe for the first time since
he was 9. bort has grown up to become a
strong and beautiful woman but are those
legs thick though she reveals that she
has been waiting for him since she saw
him the last time temujin receives a
coat as a dowry and brings bort with him
the two go to his mother and sister
after several years they are welcomed
wholeheartedly by the family for the
next month they live the life of their
dreams temujin and bourt fall deeper in
love as spouses but trouble arises when
one day they are attacked by the merkit
tribe long ago temujin's father
kidnapped his mother from the con of
merkit he had vowed to take revenge and
is here to steal bort from temujin the
couple tries running away but tamoojin
is shot with an arrow and bort is
kidnapped to become the wife of the
rival khan when temujin gets better he
knows he has to get his wife back but he
cannot do it alone hence he goes to his
old blood brother jamuka's place jamuka
has grown up to become the khan of a
powerful tribe himself he agrees to help
but only after a year because he is busy
with a task at hand a year passes in the
blink of an eye and the two then set off
with their troops to attack the merkit
tribe they kill all of their men and rob
the place before finding a pregnant
boart in one of the huts she has killed
a man whose dead body is lying beside
her temujin immediately claims that the
child is his and takes sport back at
night the troops celebrate the win by
now temujin has been able to gather a
bunch of followers they ask him to
distribute the robbed cattle and unlike
most khans temujin keeps only 10 for
himself and gives the rest to his troops
he even offers more goods to the family
of the men who died in battle two of
jamukha's people see this and decide to
join temujin's tribe since the mongols
are allowed to choose their own cons
jamuka can do nothing about it but it is
evident that he views this as a betrayal
in the following scene temujin's
soldiers see a man trying to steal their
horses they chase him down and kill him
by accident it turns out that the thief
was none other than jamuka's younger
brother after the incident jamuka makes
it his mission to kill tomujin
forgetting that he is a brother by blood
he joins hands with another tribe and
makes an attack on tamujin's tribe
tamujan knows that his people cannot win
the battle because they are heavily
outnumbered still he sends the women and
children away and makes the men fight
with all their might even after killing
several opponents temujin is caught in
the end jamuka still calls him brother
and urges him to beg for mercy he
doesn't want to kill someone who still
has strength and pride left in himself
so instead he makes him a slave and
sells him to the brokers temujin and the
remainder of his men are made to walk
several miles across the desert to reach
the city that is ruled by the tangut
dynasty after that they are kept in the
open for people to check and buy as they
please a hire official from the dynasty
comes to the market one day and shows
interest in buying to moojin his advisor
monk however sees tomujin and can tell
he is not the ideal person to be
enslaved he doesn't even have thick legs
he thinks tamoojin will be the end of
the entire powerful dynasty the buyer
only laughs at the statement and buys to
moojin nonetheless he is then kept in a
cage as a freak who people can see and
make fun of the monk visits him every
day and begs for forgiveness he makes a
pact with temujin that if he looks for
bort temujin will not destroy the
monastery when the time comes while on
the search for bort in the deserts the
monk falls unconscious and dies luckily
he is found by bort who recognizes the
necklace he has as the one she owned for
several years she figures out her
husband is still alive and goes to the
city to look for him since temujin is on
full display to the people she doesn't
take long before finding him the same
night she bribes a guard and helps
temujin flee he is surprised to see that
his son has grown a lot and bort now has
a second daughter she reluctantly had to
be with another man to make ends meet
and to feed her children temujin loves
her even more for her sacrifices and
tells the little girl that he is her
father the family of four returns to
their home in the countryside and lives
there happily for a month the kids love
their father and play with him all the
time then one day bort comments that all
mongols are the same they steal rob and
kill the comment is minute but it makes
a huge impression on tamujin he decides
to leave his family to unify as many
tribes as he can and create rule in the
world of mongols even if he has to kill
half of the tribes to get there the
three basic rules they have to follow
are never kill women and children fight
the enemies till the end and never
betray your con the scene cuts to 1196
as tamoojin vowed he has been able to
gather an army of mongols on his side
unifying several tribes and making a
massive tribe of his own the only
obstacle in his way to becoming an
absolute emperor is jamuka who also has
an army of followers behind him today
the two brothers stand on the
battlefield with their troops for the
ultimate fight it starts and jamuka
hastily sends the first batch to fight
temujin has planned the entire war while
jamuka is spontaneous which causes many
of his men to be killed after hours of
long and hard battle tamoojin wins and
captures the surviving enemy troops
including jamuka the troops are taken in
as temujin's followers instead of being
killed the gesture makes them thankful
and loyal to their new khan the old man
who once helped him escape is made the
advisor of the tribe now the only thing
left to do is to make a judgment for
jamuka the brothers sit with each other
and talk about how far they have come in
life jamuka proudly reveals he would
have killed his enemy if he was in
temujin's position right now this
further proves that he and temujin are
not the same because temujin allows him
to run away out of respect for his
brother and the hustle he has done to
create an army temujin forgives him and
lets him go then we see that bort with
both her children has reunited with
temujin and lives with him happily in
the end it is narrated that in 1206
tamujin was made the khan of all mongols
named genghis khan as he had promised he
wiped out the entire tengu dynasty and
rebuilt the kingdom but left the
monastery as it was at the request of
the late monk in the future he became
the founder of the entirety of the
mongol empire the largest contiguous
empire in history i also hear he had
great legs subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching